au bretagne on boit rarement du coca
pourtant c'est le qg des yankees
les yankee c'est l'un des dix clubs de
supporters de l'olympique de marseille
d'après leurs slogans il met la pagaille
et ne craignent personne il n'a oublié
ni tapis ni la relégation en deuxième
division et comme l' amalgame ne leur
fait pas peur la coupe du monde ici est
bannie de zinc à la cave à l'om ils nous
appellent ils en moselle de nous pour
faire vivre la coupe du monde
nous on sait ce qu'on a subi les
conséquences sans avoir aucun avantage
moi je suis supporter de l'om avant tout
le fougeux l'aiment parce que c'est un
sport que j'amenais si si j'ai pas si je
ne vibre pas pour une équipe je regarde
ça comme un spectacle quelqu'un que la
télé quoi donc l'équipe de france je
m'en fous les autres moi je m'en fous je
regarderai sûrement les grands matchs à
la télé et comme tout le monde qu'on a
tous ceux qui aiment le foot mais ça
pourrait se passer au bangladesh
les lions qui incarne l'opposition
radicale mais d'une manière générale
marseille est plus mesuré pour elle la
coupe du monde est encore loin et la
ville attend tranquillement
garde la chaîne joueurs gratuits que tu
peux garder et dit même je rate sur le
banc de touche et tu vas le van qui va
le donner
ne lui dites surtout pas qu'il est un
bon client pour les journalistes ça le
met en rogne une certitude rené
malleville est le chouchou des médias
parisiens qui aime sa gouaille son
accent son franc parler rené malleville
62 ans est un vrai amoureux de l'om il
en parle jour et nuit à la maison au bar
ou ici au stade de château gombert où il
est venu voir son petit-fils s'entraîner
l'om champion pour rené malleville ce
n'est pas un rêve il imagine déjà le
scénario parfait la victoire des
marseillais contre rennes et surtout la
victoire de caen sur bordeaux les trois
durs qu'on va faire je ne je ne conçois
pas l'om
que l'homme ne soit pas chaque pierre
fanni je pense que l'équipe est le cas
va sortir en salles du terrain et wenger
la baraka de bordeaux c'est vrai le
joueur qui comme cela mme sy le toucher
le ballon
faut le faire c'est un gag même pas dans
les dessins animés pour le ference a la
baraka énorme et pourquoi elle va durer
jusqu'à la finale c est barak le dernier
marc cultive un peu les chasses aux bon
nous donc la chance une victoire de l'om
un exploit de caen ça fait tout de même
beaucoup mais comme le dit rené 6-1
supporters ne crois pas au titre ce
n'est même pas la peine qu'ils viennent
au stade
[Musique]